captain america has the best suit of any
superhero it's not the truth
you know it's the suit for him
and it works for him but if we're
measuring against all the avengers let's
be honest it's not the best
[Music]
strongly agree agree disagree strongly i
strongly agree agree disagree strongly
disagree
great
movie set props is totally normal three
two one yeah uh you know i'm into that
come on yeah i'm just into theft in
general yeah me too it doesn't happen
doesn't matter if it's
who owns things you know that's such
like a weird human concept it's like oh
this is mine
until it's mine
what kind of things have you stolen me
hearts mind souls
moments
ideas
you know i always try to steal something
from set um but then
years will pass and i'm like what the
hell is this
i'm like oh that was that thing from
that movie what about stealing something
out of love for something like for
someone
and it's a loving gesture i once stole i
shoplifted a bunch of flowers for my
mother and i was young i was about ten
and she i got home i said here you go
look there's these flowers she said
would you get them out of it and i
didn't think they're far ahead
i said i found some money
she said you stole these didn't you i
said yes she said there's the kindest
sweetest thing you've ever done
[Laughter]
i am excellent at karaoke three two one
i i i don't know if i'm excellent i'm
i'm okay i'm gonna say disagree for
myself like i'm not the strongest singer
you know i was actually meant to be a
singer i could have been a singer but i
can't sing right right
but
i was
it was my calling sure it just didn't
work out i did not say it
neither did my voice in terms of i'm
enthusiastic with karaoke sure all the
way out here i think that's all that's
required of karaoke so my enthusiasm i
think is what pushes me onto this side
of the greek you may all disagree with
it personally that's your own opinion
what are your karaoke tunes what would
you go for me i would go for something
about prince i'll prince that's a baldy
it's a tall order um
i mean i suppose maybe a little bit of
billy joel james taylor if i'm feeling
you know a little more
uh emotional captain america has the
best suit of any superhero three two one
i i i have to i mean look i'm obviously
a little biased but
we have to we have to play
by our truths
it's not the truth it's not that's not
the truth it's not the truth not the
truth
it's the suit for him
and it works for him but if we're
measuring against all the avengers let's
be honest it's not the best
i mean [ __ ] they're all better than mine
whether it's whether it's scarlet
whether it's hemsworth whether it's tom
holland i mean they're that they all
work tom does a great job with his suit
he does he pulls it off he really does
yeah mustaches are better than beards
three two one
better i don't know if that better
better i don't know if i can say better
i mean you're really pitting me against
it this is set up for failure to sit up
between us you know you're trying to put
us against each other
we're friends i was just gonna say he
has a mustache i have a beard you know
what out of our friendship i'm not
moving my glasses me neither i'm just
gonna take a sip of water cheers cheers
cheers to your face rugby is better than
american football three two well i'm
biased i mean all right
this is where we break up yeah wait now
uh ozzy rules rugby oh no no no this is
like rugby union this is a traditional
rugby i grew up with it i didn't grow up
with american football you know and um
well nobody's perfect no that's right no
one's worth it you know i used to kind
of really
preach the fact that american football
was was
more dangerous but then i saw aussie
rules
rugby where these guys every guy is six
foot five and they have these open field
tackles that are just brutal um but but
again i grew up with american football
and
it's it's too dear to me to to think
anything is better i agree to disagree i
grew up with rugby i played rugby all my
life and
that's my favorite sport
pineapple on pizza is incredible three
two one
now you know i i
because i don't know
i've never had it
you disagree you trust me
what do you think about my opinion on
foods i'll say i disagree just because
he's got a very trusting face yeah
i've had a lot of pizza with pineapple
when i was a kid
hawaiian pizza
it was very popular i loved it but i
feel like i've been shamed into not
liking it and i feel like really that
actually informed me that informed my
decision seemed like something i don't
know if i really want to do this
what part of you is i think i can agree
like the time it's like you don't have
to just based on that i never had it
this is going to be very controversial
we're going to get a lot of hate online
for this yeah the people who don't like
pineapple i don't care
i'm from the pacific polynesia we love
pineapples what are your dream pizza
toppings what do you like to have dream
pizza toppings another pizza on top it's
my turn you ever had a pizza with it
it's like two pizzas it's like a
sandwich pizza
i mean
i i not not to deviate from the question
but can we all respect the fact that
cheese inside the crust who saw that
coming you thinking
i think you did it all
and you think oh cheese inside the crust
that's that's thinking outside the box
this is the human being's ability just
to take something that's the ingenuity
the ingenuity to change it up holy
flowers
now they're making split the atom cheese
inside the crust though that's our real
mark in the universe the new zealand
accent is the sexiest in the world three
two one i mean yeah
i couldn't say strongly because you're
pretty much the only one i know so i
agree based on you but i can't imagine
everyone has the same magic you have
no
so this is this is an agree with a like
a a ribbon of compliment
i like that i strongly agree would have
built this i see compliments as
boomerang so it's coming right back at
you your accent
really is like you know it's i know a
lot of americans yeah
you're
which is why you're in this movie you
know your voice it's a really it's
but i'll take it cats are better than
dogs three two one i'm gonna have to i'm
not going to strongly disagree because i
respect cats and i love folks who are
cats and salt cats either or finland
they're beautiful beautiful animals
personally
i'd rather have a dog around yeah me too
i grew up with dogs as well i think it's
what you're grown up with then you know
that you're most comfortable with yeah
why do you think people prefer dogs than
cats just in general cats are [ __ ]
i love working with the person opposite
me three
two absolutely i'd make every movie with
taika if i could chris is the reason i
said yes to buzz lightyear in this
industry for me i just want to work with
friends and people that have a good
energy with who just you know aren't
um difficult who aren't the cats of the
industry
this went very well
was that guy on set who just had a hit a
car on wheels and thomas yeah thomas
that's right yeah and all he did was
make lightsabers and every take we'd be
handed a new one
and nowadays they're different they're
different now i sort of missed the old
ones to be honest they had a nice feel
to them
yeah yeah the real clash together it's
the good old days
lightsabers aren't where they used to be